bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france 19 milliards d'euros
vont donc être investis dans nos
établissements nos établissements de
santé c'est ce qu'a déclaré jean castex
on viens de l'entendre comment
accueillez vous cette nouvelle est ce
que vous êtes satisfaite s'est dit fier
d'être satisfaite de ces annonces quand
on voit comment ça s'est passé avec le
premier ségur de là sans fin avec le
secteur de la santé tout court
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de on n'a pas vu
de différence sur le terrain depuis juin
on a toujours autant de personnes qui
quittent l'hôpital
est-ce que ce plan va essayer va
améliorer les conditions d'accueil de
nos patients j'en doute fortement
jean castex a déclaré également que ce
lancement du plan d'investissement est
une étape qui permet de regagner
confiance en l'avenir vous visiblement
ça ne vous donne pas confiance
bah pas du tout des chiffres ont peu
joué avec qui on joue avec comme on veut
c'est comme d'habitude cd effet
d'annonce on parle de 2 19 milliards sur
dix ans je si je dis pas de bêtises je
crois que c'est 3 et quelques milliards
la première année 3 à quelques milliards
la deuxième année ça laisse plus
beaucoup de choses pour les huit années
qui restent derrière et ensuite on a
l'ondam cette année qui va encore nous
obliger à faire 9 millions d'économies
donc c'est bien d'investir mais avec
toutes les économies qu'on nous demande
de faire c'est pas possible
pareil on a un investissement dans des
dents des demandes rh d'intérim
parce qu'on a tellement soignants qui
quittent l'hôpital qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans l'incapacité de pouvoir avoir des
équipes complètes et on dépense des
sommes astronomiques dedans donc il est
peut-être temps de se poser la question
de pourquoi les soignants quitte
l'hôpital et de prendre des réelles
mesures pour essayer de garder les
soignant à l'hôpital
ça fait deux mois ça fait deux ans
maintenant qu'on se bat pour ça ça fait
deux ans qu'on a trois revendications
que les trois revendications sont
toujours les mêmes qu'elles sont
toujours pas écouté qu'on passe toujours
un côté et et c'est assez frustrant en
fait vous n'avez pas de noter en fait
d'amélioration du système de santé
depuis depuis le ségur de la santé il ya
maintenant sept mois
pas du tout il va falloir se rendre
compte en moyenne alors que le
gouvernement se rend compte aussi que le
secteur de la santé ça a été un échec
ça n'a pas fonctionné du tout plus que
jamais les soignants quitte l'hôpital ça
n'a rien changé au niveau des mentalités
et personne n'a envie de rester dans un
bateau qui coule en fait et le bateau
coule maintenant que réclamez-vous au
gouvernement pour améliorer ce système
de santé les conditions travail
évidemment des soignants mais a toujours
la même chose en fait on a besoin de
plus de lits on a besoin d'arrêter les
fermetures de lits c'est très
intéressant de parler de rénovation et
de revoir ravalement de façade mais
quand on sait qu'il ya des hôpitaux qui
ferment et qu'il ya des milliers de lits
qui continuent de fermer tous les mois
c'est inadmissible quand on sait que il
nous manque des personnels pour pouvoir
armer les lits pour pouvoir être là voir
s'occuper des patients c'est
inadmissible non plus et quand on
demande une réelle revalorisation
salariale et une erreur une réelle
revalorisation en général de nos métiers
c'est pour éviter que les parce que les
soignants s'en aille en fait c'est beau
de dire qu'on va former plus
d'infirmiers et plus de médecins mais si
on se pose pas la question de pourquoi
tout le monde s'en va
au final on aura plus personne on se
souvient bien sûr des grèves qui ont eu
lieu avant la pandémie l'hôpital
notamment les urgences 1 faisait grève
régulièrement la crise sanitaire ce que
vous considérez qu'est laquelle a quand
même permis de mettre en exergue vos
revendications et ce qu'elle a permis
une prise de conscience
elle a permis une prise de conscience du
grand public qui est qui connaît
maintenant les réelles difficultés de
l'hôpital
maintenant est ce qu'il ya une prise de
conscience du gouvernement ça j'en doute
quand on voit les mesures qui sont
toujours insuffisantes
on se dit que le
c'est une prise de conscience de façade
pour la com mais qu'en réalité yao keane
aucun une compréhension de la gravité et
de danger de la situation dans laquelle
on est charge aux ars des labourés avant
la fin d'année une stratégie sélectionné
également les projets qu'elle considère
comme prioritaire pour vous les projets
prioritaires c'est quoi pour
bénéficiaires de ce budget annoncé par
jean castex
ça va être de remettre de l'argent dans
des dents des services qui sont en train
de fermer dans des hôpitaux qui sont en
train de fermer deux de travailler sur
l'attractivité des postes et sur le
maintien surtout des soignants pourquoi
est ce que les soignants parts à
l'hôpital j'ai vraiment se poser cette
question
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation on
n'a pas envie d'y rester on n'a pas
envie de de faire votre carrière parce
que c'est fatigant parce qu'on nous
écoute pas parce que quand on remonte un
problème c'est toujours quelque chose
qui vient nous on n'a jamais de
solutions à apporter à nos problèmes et
on a vraiment besoin d'être les prix en
plantes d'être écouté et on n'a plus
besoin de cadeaux et de bisous sur le
front et de câlins pour nous faire
passer la pilule on a besoin d'être
vraiment écouté d'être pris en compte
dans la globalité
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions marie pierre martin je précise
que les ars sont les agences régionales
de santé
et je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
du collectif intérieur jans merci pour
vos précisions